at the edge of the seven Carpathian
Mountains forest rangers Daniel who desi
and Matteo Michaelis who are braving the
snow and freezing temperatures in search
of one of the continents largest
inhabitants the recent or European bison
they locate the herd in a mountain
meadow most of the animals were released
here just a short time ago it's really
something special to be able to see
decent in the wild again they were
raised in captivity and we've released
them into these forests so many years
after the species disappeared from the
area the last animal of its kind to roam
this range was killed around 200 years
ago ever since then the European bison
was extinct in the wild reintroducing
the genus proof challenging human beings
pose the greatest threat to the large
herbivores more and more villages are
spreading into the reasons habitat
cameras set up by conservationists
observe the herd in this footage dogs
from surrounding villages have formed a
pack and are hunting the animals their
owners leave the dogs to find their own
food the emaciated canines see the half
domesticated bison as a ready meal
project leader Audra and Hatice is still
optimistic he's hoping that large herds
will soon be roaming through the
Carpathians but for this to succeed he
needs the support of the villagers
bonanza exists though when we started
reintroducing these ins into the wild we
worked hard to integrate local people in
the process
to ensure they would accept the project
and it appears that little by little the
surrounding communities are becoming
accustomed to their new neighbors we pay
a visit to a village with one of the
Rangers deer wild boar and the
occasional bear are nothing unusual
around here but the reasons which can
weigh up to a tonne are something new
this one has made itself a home in a
farmers barnyard the hay is tasty and
provides a warm place to sleep by the
herd when it was near this village so he
came straight here now he's found a
place to stay for the time being the
Rangers talk to farmers who have
reported close encounters and try to
reassure them I got close to the animal
and wanted to give it some bread
and he came at me with his horns it's
scared of daylights out of everything
conservationists have their work cut out
for them when it comes to persuading the
farmers to welcome their new neighbors
it'll still be some time before the
Bison have resettled here deep in the
forests of the southern carpathians
you